salut c'est l'ego j'espère que vous
allez bien alors on a deux jours du
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
aujourd'hui on va donc comparer les
programmes d' emmanuel macron et de
marine le pen alors au début j'avais
pensé avec mon équipe à faire une vidéo
qui montre les différences et les points
communs entre les deux candidats de
manière exhaustive sur quasiment tous
les sujets j'ai réalisé assez rapidement
que ça donnerait soit une vidéo 5h trop
longue soit trop simpliste du coup
changement de format j'ai choisi de me
centrer sur di différence majeure dans
leurs programmes ce qui me semble être
donc un bon équilibre n'hésitez pas
évidemment à vous abonner je ne sais pas
encore le cas il ya plein de belles
choses qui arrivent sur sa chaîne au
delà de la présidentielle sur plein de
sujets les reportages aussi qu'on va
reprendre dans les prochains jours j'ai
très hâte de vous montrer tout ça et on
est donc parti sans plus tarder avec le
premier point alors la première chose
sur laquelle emmanuel macron et marine
le pen sont en désaccord total c'est au
sujet de l'union européenne on a d'un
côté emmanuel macron qui est un pro
européen convaincu qui souhaite
renforcer les liens de la france avec
l'union européenne que ce soit en
matière de défense d'économie d'énergie
ou encore d'écologie de l'autre côté on
à marine le pen qui est plutôt
eurosceptiques et se montre très
critique envers l'union européenne elle
a certes abandonné l'idée de sortir de
l'euro et de l'union européenne chose
qu'elle portait en 2017 et encore plus
en 2012 mais elle souhaite aujourd'hui
renégocier les traités européens par
exemple elle voudrait rendre le droit
français supérieur au droit européen ou
encore baisser les contributions
financières de la france à l'union
européenne la deuxième différence
majeure entre marine le pen et emmanuel
macron concerne à l'international et
notamment les relations entre la france
et la russie en fait avant l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie marine le pen
était clairement pro russe jugeant que
la france devait parler autant à la
russie qu'aux états unis par ailleurs et
bien elle avait rencontré vladimir
poutine lors de la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 elle avait été
par ailleurs l'une des rares
personnalités politiques en france a
validé en 2014 l'annexion par la russie
du territoire ukrainien de la crimée
alors aujourd'hui dans cette campagne
présidentielle changement de ton elle
condamne très clairement l'invasion de
l'ukraine par la russie et soutient par
ailleurs plusieurs sanctions qui ont été
prises contre la russie cependant elle
ne souhaite pas aller comme le veut
aimer le maquereau jusqu'à l'embargo sur
le pétrole et le gaz venant de russie un
embargo qui pourrait selon elle nuire au
pouvoir d'achat des français du côté des
manuels macron sa relation avec vladimir
poutine au début de son quinquennat
était assez ambiguë avec à la fois une
réception à versailles et puis résidence
de vacances des présidents au fort de
brégançon mais aussi avec vladimir
poutine des échanges tendus sur un
certain nombre de sujets aujourd'hui
vous l'avez sûrement suivi dans le
résumé est d'actualité sur youtube ou
instagram mais le président candidat
souhaite continuer de sanctionner
fortement la russie fournir par ailleurs
des armes à l'ukraine et assume
pleinement que la france fasse partie de
l'otan cette alliance militaire donc
menée par les états unis avec de
nombreux pays européens tout en poussant
par ailleurs pour la création d'une
armée européenne
quant à marine le pen sur cette question
de l'otan elle souhaite elle sortir du
commandement intégré de l'otan la
troisième différence majeure entre le
programme du candidat de la république
en marche et celui de la candidate du
rassemblement national c'est au sujet de
l'immigration sur ce sujet la marine le
pen est bien plus radicale qui est venu
et le maquereau elle souhaite réduire
drastiquement l'immigration et c'est
réellement au coeur de son projet et se
maintenant depuis des années et
historiquement au sein de son parti pour
ce faire elle veut modifier la
constitution donc la loi suprême du pays
pour pouvoir appliquer son programme
elle propose par exemple de réserver
certaines aides sociales aux français ou
encore d'accorder la priorité dans le
cadre d'une offre d'emploi ou encore
d'un logement aux français par rapport
aux étrangers ce qui serait forcément un
changement majeur pour des millions de
personnes en france de son côté même
s'il parle moins d'immigration que son
adversaire et minutes macron a malgré
tout proposer certains changements
visant à réduire l'immigration illégale
il souhaite par exemple accélérer les
décisions pour les demandes d'asile afin
d'expulser plus rapidement donc ceux qui
n'ont pas le droit à l'asile en france
je veux aussi mettre fin au recours ce
qui veut dire que si l'état refuse une
première fois une demande d'asile il
vient la personne étrangère doit quitter
le pays directement voilà donc ces
différences majeures des deux candidats
sur ce sujet 4e différence marquante
désormais entre les deux candidats c'est
au sujet des institutions voulait
peut-être vu d'ailleurs lors du débat
mercredi marine le pen veut mettre en
place le rique donc le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne
c'est en fait une proposition qui vient
notamment des gilet jaune et qui
consiste en gros à ce qu'un sujet puisse
être soumis au référendum donc au vote
de la population directement si jamais
ce sujet a recueilli cinq cent mille
signatures de citoyens par exemple via
une plateforme en ligne 2 au côté menu
le maquereau n'est pas favorable à ce
rica ce référendum d'initiative
citoyenne et plus largement la c'est
important de comprendre que émules macro
et marine le pen ont deux approches
différentes dans leurs manières
d'exercer le pouvoir s'ils sont élus en
gros marine le pen pourrait avoir du mal
à obtenir une majorité de députés à
l'assemblée nationale
car le mode d'élection est
historiquement moins favorables au parti
d'extrême droite du coup elle pourrait
tenter de gouverner par référendum
concrètement ça veut dire qu'on tournait
le vote des élus et faire voter ses
projets majeurs sur l'immigration par
exemple par la population directement
via ses référendum le problème c'est que
selon de nombreux juristes marine le pen
pourrait avoir des difficultés à faire
passer certaines de ses lois par
référendum comme le référendum qu'elle
souhaite proposer sur l'immigration qui
pourrait être contraire à la
constitution donc à la loi suprême du
pays je vais pas rentrer là dessus dans
les détails parce que c'est forcément
des éléments assez technique et d'un
point de vue juridique mais je vais vous
voulez plus d'informations comme
d'habitude vous le savez pour comprendre
le débat là dessus je vous mets des
liens directement en descriptions 5e
différence ça concerne l'économie sujet
sur lequel emmanuel macron et marine le
pen sont là aussi sur deux visions
différentes le président sortant est
plutôt libérale et de son côté et bien
marine le pen est plutôt
protectionnistes en gros elle souhaite
globalement limité les échanges
commerciaux avec l'étranger pour bien
protéger davantage les entreprises
françaises de la concurrence et elle
s'est aussi à nationalisé plusieurs
entreprises donc faire en sorte qu'elle
devienne les entreprises gérées
directement par l'état le sixième point
de désaccord que je voulais souligner
c'est quelque chose que vous avez
sûrement là aussi vu ces derniers jours
dans l'actualité celui de l'âge de
départ à la retraite en gros émules
macron souhaite que les français
travaillent plus longtemps il considère
en fait que l'espérance de vie s'allonge
aussi son programme mentionne le chiffre
de 65 ans mais il s'est dit prêt à le
modifier éventuellement à 64 ans je cite
s'il ya trop de tensions et sur les
retraites au delà de cet allongement il
souhaite par ailleurs garantir une
pension de retraite minimale à hauteur
de 1100 euros par mois ça c'est donc
pour l'actuel président candidat du côté
de marine le pen est bien elle ne
souhaite pas modifier l'âge de départ à
la retraite et le maintenir en fait à 62
ans mais veut permettre à ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt et bien
de pouvoir partir encore plus tôt à
l'âge donc de 60 ans et ce s'ils ont
cotisé 40 ans autre différence qu on
pourrait noter c'est sur la question de
l'énergie en gros au niveau du nucléaire
ils sont globalement alignés pour rester
avec cette source d'énergie qui est
majeur aujourd'hui mais au sujet des
énergies renouvelables emmanuel macron
souhaite développer le solaire et
l'éolien avec par exemple la
construction de 50 parcs d'éoliennes en
mer d'ici à 2050
marine le pen de son côté s'opposent
fortement aux éoliennes elle juge que ça
pollue notamment les paysages et si elle
est élue eh bien elle n'en construira
plus aucune et démantèlera toutes celles
qui sont déjà construites il ya par
ailleurs des différences évidemment sur
les sujets environnementaux forcément un
sujet majeur qu'on a beaucoup traité de
notre côté sur la chaîne au delà de la
simple question de l'énergie je voulais
plus d'informations sur les différences
de vision sur l'environnement je voulais
plusieurs liens vers des vidéos qu'on a
réalisé notamment directement en
description on passe à la 8ème
différences de programmes majeurs entre
marine le pen emmanuel macron elle
concerne les mesures pour les jeunes
alors même si leur programme ont
quelques similitudes comme le refus que
le rsa donc ce revenu pour les personnes
précaires soit étendue aux 18 à 25 ans
il propose quand même des choses assez
différentes pour les jeunes marine le
pen propose par exemple de supprimer les
impôts sur le revenu pour tous les moins
de 30 ans quelle que soit par ailleurs
leur niveau de revenu et de rendre
gratuits les trains pour les moins de 25
ans aux heures creuses de ce côté le
candidat de la république en marche
propose plutôt de mettre en place une
aide financière
les jeunes de 16 à 25 ans qui ne sont ni
étudiant ni salarié mais à condition de
suivre des heures de formation pour les
aider à s'insérer dans le marché de
l'emploi c'est ce qu'il appelle le
contrat d'engagement jeunes un
dispositif qui a commencé à être mise en
place début mars la 9e différence elle
est sur le pouvoir d'achat c'est un
thème fort de la campagne emmanuel
macron et marine le pen ont tous les
deux annoncé qu'ils n'augmenteront pas
le salaire minimum donc le smic y aura
pas d'augmentation s'ils sont élus en
revanche tous les deux compte instaurer
des mécanismes pour inciter les
entreprises à augmenter les salaires et
c'est là qu'on peut y voir une
différence marine le pen propose que
pendant cinq ans lorsqu'une entreprise
augmente de plus de 10% le salaire d'un
salarié et bien elle n'est plus à payer
de cotisations sociales sur cette
augmentation de salaire emmanuel macron
de son côté propose plutôt de développer
son système de primes s'en charge pour
le passé à 6000 euros par an et pareil
les l'idée c'est quoi c'est que un
employeur peut verser jusqu'à 6000 euros
de primes directement à son employé sans
qu'il y ait de cotisation ou quoi que ce
soit c'est 6000 euros maximum qui vont
directement dans le compte de l'employé
enfin 10e différence c'est sur les
sujets de société alors il ya forcément
pas mal de choses différentes partagent
elles n'ont pas la même vision sur la
pma donc la procréation médicale
assistée ce dispositif qui permet pour
faire vraiment très simple à un couple
ou à une femme seule qui a du mal à
avoir un enfant d'en avoir un grâce à un
accompagnement médical emmanuel macron
est pur il a même fait passer une loi
sous son dernier mandat pour l'élargir à
toutes les femmes y compris les couples
de femmes ou son côté marine le pen et
contre la pma pour toutes en revanche
elle n'a pas affirmé qu'elle
supprimerait la loi si elle devenait
présidente ça c'est pour les différents
cela dit on peut noter qu'ils sont tout
de même tous les deux opposé à la
légalisation de la gpa donc le fait
qu'une femme porte un enfant pour un
autre couple de parents ils sont par
ailleurs tous les deux contre la
légalisation du cannabis voilà donc pour
cette vidéo pas évident forcément résumé
deux programmes en quelques minutes et
de faire émerger comme ça les
différences de vision essayez donc d'en
faire ressortir un maximum ici sachant
que vous le savez pour en savoir plus
c'est bien cette vidéo vient en
complément de tous les autres contenus
on a eu l'occasion de faire ces derniers
jours à l'occasion de cette élection
présidentielle les interviews des
candidats les décryptages des programmes
etc par ailleurs il ya pas mal le
comparatif qu'on a fait notamment sur
instagram pouvez le voir sur notre
compte instagram et bien différents
comparatifs de programmes sur pas mal de
sujets n'hésitez pas évidemment à vous
abonner je ne sais pas encore le cas
pour nous soutenir et pour ne pas louper
les vidéos suivantes au delà de la
présidentielle comme je le disais en
début de vidéo enfin chez mais ça vous
intéresse et que vous voulez vivre cette
soirée électorale dimanche avec nous je
refais un live sur twitter avec mon
équipe encore dimanche ça se passe donc
sur ma chaîne fritsch yugo décrypte on
annoncera les résultats en direct à 20h
et ont des bris fera aussi évidemment
tout ça le nom du complot de la chaîne
s'il veut décrypte n'hésitez pas à
prenez soin de vous proposer à nos
proches et on se dit ah très vite